we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p this i think
is going to be the final word on
distractions on the program take a
listen to this
hey David Brent from Jersey City calling
I just had a quick question for you you
know we've heard about the Bernie
Sanders distraction we know all about
the producer pad distraction
last week we were hit over the head with
an emergency appendectomy distraction my
question is are all these distractions
just a distraction right thanks you know
in a sense they are and I feel as though
unfortunately we have all become so
distracted by identifying and
adjudicating varying degrees of
distractions that I want to put an end
to the distraction and let it be known
right now there will be no more
distractions including the discussions
of such distractions I am closing the
book on it we've got a great bonus show
for you today
NATO's Stoltenberg is defending the NATO
stance on Turkey's offensive in Syria
what is that stance and what are the
implications we're gonna dig into that
on today's bonus show because by request
there has been more policy discussion
requested for the bonus show number two
there is a one-year-old girl who has
died after being left in a car all day
tragic horrible every time we hear about
one of these stories this is the 50th
hot car death in 2019 and I want to
discuss what is behind this and there's
actually a sort of macabre tie-in that
oh I won't I won't spoil it now but
there's something I want to discuss on
the bonus show related to that we will
also talk about incoming or possibly
already made endorsements of Bernie
Sanders candidacy in 2020 by Ilan Omar
Alexandria Acacio Cortes and maybe
Rasheeda Talib we will talk about those
endorsements and endorsements more
generally on the bonus show
it is a jam-packed bonus show I will
also have news about the Vegas
Conference of next week it's not the
most exciting news unfortunately
but maybe some people will like it and I
will update you on the progress of the
membership drive that we have been doing
over the last five days all of that
stuff and much more on today's bonus
show get instant access to ways number
one become a member by signing up at
join pakman.com number to become a
patron by pledging at least $5 a month
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
speak to you then